So the ADD is peer producing a value of R1.
That is not a problem because the previous instruction is just for
using R2. So the ADD can't write its result when it's time. And when it,
it's executed in cycle three, so it's going to write in cycle five.
Now let's look at this multiplication instruction over here.
Remember, we can execute any number of instructions. In the, in the same cycle.
The reason we had to delay the ADD is because it actually has this dependence
from R2 to R2. The multiplication is using only R3 and producing R3.
Using R3 has no problem because neither the mul, nor the add are producing R3 so
this multiplication can actually execute in cycle two.
And then, there is no problem with R3 here because there is only R1 and
R2, written by the previous instruction. So
this multiplication can actually write R3 in cycle four. Because it's like two,
three, four. Now, let's look at this ADD here. It uses R1 and R3. The R1 it's
supposed to be using is produced by this ADD. Which executes in cycle three.
The R3 is produced in cycle two by the multiplication. So this instruction
actually has to wait for cycle four because of this. Then it's going to be cycle
five when it's in the MEM stage. And it's able to write its result in cycle six.
It's going to override the result from the ADD here but because the ADD is
writing in cycle five. It's okay if we write in cycle six so everything is fine.
Here we can write in cycle six. Now let's look at the multiplication here.
It's using R4 none of the other instructions are producing R4.
So it can also execute in the second cycle. It produces R4. None of the previous
instructions are writing it so we have, we don't have to wait for anything. So
we can actually write our R4 in cycle four as well. Just like this amount here.
And then finally let's look at this add here. It's using R1 from here.
It's using R4 from here. So our execution has to be
in the cycle that follows the larger of these two. The larger is the cycle four,
so we have to begin our execution in cycle five here. At the end of cycle five,
then we will have the result. And the MEM, we can write the result in
cycle seven. But we have to check, is somebody else going to override it later.
And that's not going to happen, because if we write here in cycle seven,
we are safe. This is the latest instruction, it should do the write of the,
of the R1 at the latest time among all the other instructions. And if you
look at the previous instructions have written the results in cycle five and
cycle six. So it's okay if we here write it in cycle seven.
So this is the solution to the quiz.